hi guys welcome to an other video by
simply learn today we are going to see
the different types of cloud computing
service models so let's get started
what's in it for you first we are gonna
see what is cloud computing then the
different types of service models and
then we are going to see the key
features pros and cons of each then we
are going to see the top companies
providing these service models and
finally the end users of these service
models what is cloud computing before we
go into cloud computing what does the
term cloud mean cloud refers to a
network or Internet it provides services
over public and private networks so many
applications execute on the cloud and
also it is present at a very remote
location so the users can access these
files and applications that is present
on the cloud from any device unless and
until it has strong internet
connectivity now let's look at few of
the cloud computing benefits the first
is cloud computing you reduces cost so
it is a pay-as-you-go pricing and you
pay for what service you use next cloud
backs up and restores huge amounts of
data so let's take an example
we knew that iPhone uses iCloud for
backup if in case the phone crashes all
the backed up data can be restored cloud
computing is highly reliable and this is
one of the biggest advantages you can
always get instant updates about the
changes cloud based applications
automatically refresh and update
themselves this saves valuable IT staff
time and money spent on updating and
refreshing the applications like I've
said before cloud computing has
unlimited storage capacity at any time
you can expand your storage capacity
with very nominal monthly fees now that
we know what cloud computing is let's
look at the types of cloud computing
service models for a better
understanding let's consider a scenario
consider making lasagna you have four
options you can either bake it at home
or you can go to a restaurant to eat
lasagna or walk into an event and bake
or get it delivered to your door
step but how is this related to cloud
computing well let's take a look we have
four boxes we have the traditional
method we have the infrastructure as a
service we have platform as a service
and we have software as a service in the
traditional method everything is made at
home and all the components are managed
by us that is kitchen electricity
microwave lasagna sheets then toppings
meat and cooking the lasagna but when it
comes to infrastructure service the main
kitchen appliances are managed by the
vendor and the other things are managed
by us so basically the infrastructure is
managed by the vendor when we look at
platform and service the infrastructure
and the main ingredient for the software
is managed by the vendor and the other
things are managed by us but when we
look at software as a service everything
from the infrastructure till the end
product is managed by the window now
let's get into brief of all this when we
look at the traditional method
everything is done from scratch from
choosing the right ingredients to the
mode of preparation and have the full
control of the toppings this is similar
to traditional method where all the
hardware software components are built
by a choice of requirements when you
look at infrastructure as a service we
can say kitchen electricity and
microwave is the infrastructure and this
is where the code runs the next step is
to alter the software as per our
requirements when you look at platform
as a service it's similar to going to
event and baking so you have the main
ingredient there is a lasagna sheet and
then you have all the appliances that is
kitchen electricity and microwave and
the rest is managed by us you can add
the put toppings or you don't want to
put meat or you wanted to be veg it's
all up to us so the components are
altered as per our requirements
finally in software service the entire
thing is modeled by the vendor so this
is where you just given your
requirements and you get the software
delivered to you it's basically where
the deployment and framework of the
project is already set now that we have
a brief of all these services let's dive
deep into each one of them first we have
infrastructure as a service
infrastructure cloud provider gives a
variety of infrastructures such as tour
aged services network hardware and so on
it
so maintains and supports these
infrastructures customers can access
these resources over the Internet next
let's look at the benefits of
infrastructure as a service so the first
feature is that these resources can
easily be scaled up and down next the
cost depends on the consumption so
basically it's a pay-as-you-go pricing
and you pay for what you use you pay for
the services you use a single piece of
server can give out a lot of information
to many users and finally the client has
complete control over the architecture
now let's look at the pros of
infrastructure as a service model
firstly it is highly flexible this is
because only the infrastructure is
provided and the rest depends on the
customer requirements next like I said
before it is cost effective and you pay
for what you use it is easy to use as
all the updates are deployed and all the
hardware is deployed automatically
management tasks are wash alized so that
the other employees have time for other
tasks now let's look at few of its call
it is a multi-tenant architecture due to
this there is an issue with data
security when a new infrastructure is
introduced team training is required to
learn all about this new infrastructure
and it consumes a lot of time if in case
the so crashes at the vendor side the
customers cannot access the data for a
while and they would have to wait for
quite a lot of time until the window
fixes this issue now that we know what
infrastructure as a service is let's
look at platform as a service platform
as a service cloud computing platform is
a developer programming platform which
is used for the programmers to develop
test and run and manage the applications
a developer drives the applications and
deploys it directly into this layer all
the infrastructure to run the
applications will be over the Internet
let's look at the benefits now firstly
the resources can be scaled up and down
based on the requirements of the user
multiple users can access the same
application it allows for testing and
hosting apps in the same environment the
web services and databases and servers
are integrated into one and finally the
teams can collaborate very easily next
let's look at the pros of paas firstly
the development process
is quick and easy as it is a developer
programming platform it is
cost-efficient you only pay for those
services you use when you use
platform-as-a-service the coding is done
by the developer before so less coding
is required and then the migration to
hybrid cloud is very easy
next let's look at few of the cons of
platform-as-a-service similar to IAS
data security is an issue because it has
a multi-tenant architecture there is a
compatibility issue with the existing
infrastructure pass is dependent on the
window speed reliability and support now
that we know about platform as-a-service
let's go ahead and dive deep into
software as a service and software as a
service everything is done by the
vendors the end-users are only
responsible to give their requirements
and everything is done by the providers
now let's go ahead and look at its
benefits the installations and updations
are done by the providers resources are
scaled up and down based on requirements
of the users the only requirement is
that there has to be a strong network
connectivity and finally the provider is
responsible for everything now let's go
ahead and look at the pros of SAS
upgrades are automatic firstly then next
it is again a pay-as-you-go model it is
easier to customize in SAS rather than
the other service models it is
accessible from any location the only
constraint is that you need to have a
strong internet connectivity let's see
the cons of SAS the provider has an try
or control the end users only have the
control of giving the requirements there
are only few solutions for software
crashes the devices should always be
connected for better performance now
that we've seen all the three models
let's see few of the companies providing
these service models the famous is
providers are Amazon Web Services
Rackspace digital ocean Linode and
Microsoft Azure these are only a few
there are many more apart from these
Amazon offers many features such as auto
scaling cloud monitoring and load
balancing features when Castro Rackspace
the cloud computing platform window
focuses family on enterprise level
hosting services when you look at famous
fast provider
you have Hiroko Apache Stratus openshift
Microsoft Azure and many other providers
going ahead in SAS providers the most
important one is Google Apps then the
Salesforce there is cisco webex this
Dropbox and many more finally let's look
at the end users of the cloud computing
service models we can picture this as a
pyramid so in IAS the end users a system
admins who are responsible for
maintaining everything except the
infrastructure then in pass the end
users of the developers who code on the
platform provided by the vendors in SAS
the end users are the customers who give
only the requirements and the software
is built based on those requirements by
the windows thank you for watching I
hope you found this informative and stay
tuned for more from simply learn hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here